now whilst time may be heading in a
constant direction
during your phd project the project
itself
is likely to zigzag all over the place
stopping and starting and going at full
speed or holding for breaks in between
this can be stressful
this can be challenging this can be
overwhelming
but it can also be exciting it can be
mind-blowing
it can be a great learning opportunity
to learn more about yourself
how to write plan code create
experiment and make great friends and
lifelong connections
and still so much more so hello and
welcome to the chicky science show and
whether you're a phd student
about to start a phd or are intrigued by
what may be said in this video
then watch on as we cover some top tips
and advice
on having the habits tools knowledge
mindset and enthusiasm for a phd project
and now you may be thinking what do i
know
well you're right whilst i am now just
starting my second year of phd
studying p53 and senescence at cancer
research uk
i'm not the perfect phc student with all
the answers
probably far from that and so for these
reasons i've roped in
two of my fellow phd colleagues and
friends tom and ann
to provide some of their tips and advice
as well and if you have any tips too
please drop a comment down below and
share with fellow phd students
if you think it'll be helpful for them
too so first up is having the habits
to get organized better i started to
carry a to-do list book which is often
in my back pocket
in the evening i try to write down my
next day's to-do's
it helps me to relax and gets me going
better in the morning
during the day i carry it with me and
take of tasks that i've done
note dawn tasks that pop up during the
day and write down new ideas
i also took on an advice i picked up
listening to a podcast
never attend a meeting without an agenda
so before i go into meetings i always
double check what the meeting is about
and what the output is supposed to be if
there is no agenda
and the invitation title is project
discussion i might not
attend it now for me one of the habits
i've got used to using
is a cell tracker spreadsheet so
effectively what this is is a
spreadsheet
that details the location of different
files within a box
and this may be a very biology specific
thing
but it's very easy to lose track of how
many protein lysates or different
frozen cells you've got and so i find it
very useful to have an online copy of
this
because then i can easily update it when
i take stuff out or add things back in
again
another good habit to get into is the
structuring of your file location
as this will help you to keep a good
track of where your different files are
located
such as your results or your experiment
plans because
you know three or four years down the
line you might not
quite remember where you saved that
really important information
i did make a separate video on that so
go check that out if you're interested
in more
and speaking of keeping good track of
information
this brings us on to the next section
having the tools
mendeley endnote paper pile lifesavers
additionally i have a spreadsheet with
short summaries of each paper i've read
and sticky notes on printouts of the
papers repetition is my friend in
remembering complicated papers
further on from ann's point regarding
mendeley at least you can get extensions
for your browser whether it's chrome or
brave which is what i use
which means that when you're looking at
the paper online it's really easy to
just add
the reference already to your reference
tracker
i am a big fan of the idea of focusmate
you can either use the original website
for a 50 minute session
or just team up with someone you know
and start a video call
state what you want to achieve in the
next 10 15 20 minutes
and work side by side it helps to nudge
yourself
out of the procrastination cycle that we
all have
so now let's move on to having the
knowledge which is all about
how to keep up with that gigantic pile
of papers you've got waiting to read
so for me i like using twitter to see
latest publications
though at times this can be a bit
overwhelming i make that pile of papers
even larger but the great thing is is
that many scientists
will do a twitter thread summarizing the
key points from their paper
so it's a kind of good way of
identifying papers that you would want
to read in more detail
and that you can get a quick overview
without actually having to read the
paper but obviously
this may depend on your subject i really
like reading and context
either by just annotating a copy of a
paper writing short summaries of what
i've read or discussing it with someone
else
it depends what you're working on but
writing your own code to analyze and
play around with some data from an
experiment
can really help your understanding
although that might not work for
everyone
another way of semi avoiding breeding
papers is to watch
youtube videos because that's quite a
good source of information
and if you're a biologist then there's
um
quite a good channel that you might like
and might actually be on
right now but joking aside eye biology
nature and cell abstracts and there's
plenty other different channels
are really useful to have quick
summaries of different research papers
normally produced by specialists in the
field but besides having the knowledge
it's also really important of having the
mindset or in other words how to stay
mentally grounded during your phd
project
this is the hardest part about a phd my
advice would be to pick up healthy
habits
define work hours leave work at work
find things that interest you outside of
your phd
or learn something that is just vaguely
related but not key to your phd
i for example picked up illustrator
classes and photoshop classes
which can be useful for scientific
figures or
just useful for fun and creativity
also something that i want to give you
on the way is have faith in your
supervisors and reach out if you need
help concerning your work or mental
health
a phd is a challenge but we're all in
this together and your university and
supervisors
are prepared to point you in the
directions you need if you need help
you are here to learn and to grow
this is a really challenging part of the
phd
it's really common to feel like your
work is not as good as other people's or
that you don't deserve to be here
i think this is because people wouldn't
actually tend to talk about their
successful results
rather than the many hurdles that they
have had to overcome to get there
so i think it's really important to
remember that a phd is a continuous
learning experience
you won't know everything straight away
and you won't get everything right the
first time
it's as much an opportunity to make
mistakes as it is to get things right
now the way that i like to stay mentally
grounded is by keeping my bar
green so basically i used to play sims
quite a lot as a kid
and for those of you who have played
sims they have those like green diamonds
above their heads
and that green color can go from green
down to like an orangey color to then
red
and it symbolizes how all of the needs
of that sim is met
and these different needs include things
like hunger comfort
bladder energy levels their fun
social hygiene and environment and
you always want your sim to have the
highest green bar
because then that's when your simmers
met all their needs and they're most
happy
and you know that's the most important
thing you've got to take good care of
your sim
but you've also got to take good care of
yourself and i find this way a good way
of keeping track
of the different needs that i need and
a name it may be helpful for you um it's
a quirky thing that i
do i'm a quirky person and so lastly
then
is having the enthusiasm contributing to
the understanding of cancer
growing with each task and challenge and
learning each day
i love being able to do something that
no one has ever done before
even if it's something really tiny
overcoming a challenge is just the best
feeling
particularly when your work is applied
to something as important as cancer
so regardless of what your phd is on
it's important to find some enthusiasm
to wake up each morning and to go yeah
let's do my phd
um you might not feel like that every
day um but it's
always good to kind of take a step back
and see the bigger picture
so hopefully these tips have provided
some insights and
helpful advice for whether or not you're
about to start a phd
or are doing a phd at the moment and
just the final tip
um for fun always remember to balance
the centrifuge
and put the lid on and also a big shout
out to
ann and tom for helping me out with this
video so
as always i hope you've learned
something and thanks for listening